Welcome to part two of documentary day at the
Director's Close-Up! I'm really happy with the
movement to miniseries, more economical for the
filmmakers generally and it's more economical
for the buyers they get more bang for their
buck. To be able to get a certain level of
sincerity and authenticity and still be able
to create beautiful images is just something
that keeps getting better. Then the tools are
shrinking and two or three or four people crews
could actually make amazing cinematic quality. We
were having fun kind of chasing down this bad guy,
we felt like an audience would also enjoy
it. We're basically being very responsible
trying to tell these people's stories. I'm really
interested, I'm really listening, I really care!
You're really tired of the drone shots! ah
Heidi. Oh my God, I'm like hey should we fly
the drone, we have so many in our new film!